April is financial literacy month and
Silver State Schools Credit Union is
taking care of its members with some
Education and Fun Mercedes spoke with
president and CEO Scott a arkles about
how they're helping people of all ages
meet their financial goals
Scott welcome back to the show it's so
good to see you long time no see
thank you Mercedes good to see you too
now
to last about this and I think it is so
fantastic Silver State Schools Credit
Union had some special events planned
for April because it is financial
literacy awareness month what are some
of the things that you've been doing to
recognize that uh yes thank you Mercedes
well we've done a variety of events to
bring awareness to financial literacy so
far this month and so Silver State
school's Credit Union hosted a thing
called a bite of reality event for uh
the senior class at Southwest Career
Technical Academy and so each
participating student is given a
profession a spouse children and monthly
income with which to purchase their
various needs and wants um that would be
such as housing transportation and
entertainment it's really a great
activity that provides students a
glimpse of what I like to call real life
adulthood that allows us to have a
conversation about savings budgeting
credit scores and having students really
prioritize their needs versus their
wants and I'm also excited for the
return of our money moves mobile contest
at our April Branch event uh so
contestants will have an opportunity to
win some cash by answering General
Financial questions so the more correct
answers you give the more cash you win
up to fifty dollars so it's kind of it's
a great event I know you've been
involved with us on on that in the past
as well everything you
think you were financial literacy
awareness month just is fun I love how
you make it fun
it is Mercedes and we're also excited to
provide this uh contest uh in in all of
our communities that we serve uh we also
sponsored a financial literacy webinar
for Junior and senior high school
students at West Career and Technical
Academy it was great to have you there
uh with us AMC and facilitating the uh
the webinar Mercedes and I enjoyed
talking to them and really answering all
their questions really intelligent
um uh young students uh that gives me
hope for tomorrow for sure and uh and by
the way we're going to post that video
online for the benefit for the other
students who could not attend
um and we're putting that link on our
webinar webpage uh which the
silverstatecu.com
that was such a fun time I agree with
you those kids were so smart and that's
actually the high school that my
daughter graduated from so I was happy
that these students got to learn from
you of all people they learned about
finances how to reach their financial
goals
um saving so it was a really good time
it really is important Mercedes
announced a not-for-profit member on
financial institution Silver State
Schools Credit Union supports members
with financial literacy because we serve
our members not shareholders and as your
financial partner for life we want our
members to achieve the ultimate end goal
of uh for financial literacy and that's
Financial Wellness
foreign we want to thank Silver State
Schools Credit Union for sponsoring this
segment you can call
702-733-8820 or visit
silverstatecu.com for more information